merry christmas
[Music]
now when in norway we can't stop
thinking about reindeer
so i thought i'd do a reindeer omelette
now don't get upset
because it's a sort of a spicy sausage
made from reindeer meat but it's done
with the most amazing
brown cheese now this is a traditional
cheese here it's delicious honestly it's
so rich and dense and heavy
but it's called brown because it is
literally a block of brown cheese
and what it is is the protein left over
from making the white
cheddar cheese caramelize and reduce
down so it's incredibly creamy
that's so delicious so i'm going to use
some of the
reindeer sausage okay
now the nice thing about this particular
omelet
it could be a good breakfast lunch or
dinner
slice the reindeer nice and thin
take a little bit of butter okay put
that into the pan
now the reindeer meat there's hardly any
fat in there
so get the sausage in
pretty quickly get that really nice
and toasty from there
light seasoning now
the sammy's edition using lots of
reindeer they never like you cooking
with pepper because
they never want you to sort of miss out
that flavor
from the reindeer so just salt only
mushrooms i'm just going to slice
place them in with this sausage
the secret here is to make sure i get
some really nice color
on those mushrooms and take the water
out really important
now fry that off turn the gas up
put a log in there and
i'm going to start the omelette with all
that reindeer sausage
and those mushrooms are cooked now
beautiful see the color in there now
it's almost like a sort of
and the spicy merguez and it caramelizes
get some beautiful color on there
and then on the side here i've got some
beautiful
roasted tomatoes and they're just been
slow roasted
and almost blistered and they look
absolutely beautiful
i'm sort of roasting them in the embers
so so good
[Music]
[Music]
that's the nice thing about being here
steeped in this tradition
everything's done with love
care and more importantly
nobody messes with the tradition so i'm
gonna make a
egg omelet
lightly beat that
and then look through that
and get little shavings of cheese
running through that omelette so with
that nice sort of
caramelized brown cheese flavor
that's going to help sort of give it a
little bit more richness
and because it's quite salty
it'll give a wonderful flavor to
the omelet and trust me this is not your
average omelette
this is a reindeer brown cheese on there
now that's
nice from there
check out my sausages my mushrooms
beautiful all the water's gone from the
mushroom and the sausage is nice
and crisp
my god that's delicious
[Music]
wow really delicious now
for the omni a non-stick pan
from there some butter
again locally made butter melt that
butter
eggs
all that cheese in there as well
now from there back onto the heat
we're going to mix that until we start
to set it
that's really important we don't season
it
until we're literally about to finish
cooking it
30 seconds on 30 seconds off and all i'm
doing is making sure that cheese is
melting
evenly but i want to keep the color
of this omelette nice and vibrant
look what that cheese is doing to be on
there it's sort of giving it a nice sort
of
light brown tinge almost like a
beautiful
light golden orange sunset and now from
there i'm going to season it
lightly season it pull that in
[Music]
well look at the color that
the cheese is working it's magic
the eggs are cooking nicely and then
from there
back under the heat sausages
crisp and delicious
until that mushroom's got color
now turn that over
so let that cook now the secret behind
any grey omelette
is make sure that it's not dry in the
center so you just want a
little touch of liquid just a touch
[Music]
it starts to get to three-quarter cut
stage
keep it nice and flat and then from
there
sprinkle your reindeer
sausage and your mushrooms on
look at that beautiful really beautiful
and then on top of that
i'm going to layer this beautiful
brown cheese on top
so it causes that nice creamy
texture in the center
so lay that out all nice and flat look
at that
beautiful back on the heat
amazing so beautiful then one
final season on top of that before i
start folding it
[Music]
now as it sits underneath that's my base
i've got that beautifully caramelized
reindeer sausage the mushrooms are
nicely colored and that cheese is going
to semi-melt
but in the center it's going to be nice
and sort of
moist in a way that it's a sort of a
creamy
delicious omelette and now for the
exciting part we're going to fold it
down
and tip it out so
now tap it a few times
that stops it from sticking get your
spatula
in and just literally start folding that
over
nicely oh
boy are you kidding me oh my god
just lay a nice little layer that cheese
on top
my delicious reindeer sausage
brown cheese omelet check this out
oh man
that is delicious
let me know in the comments what you
think of that amazing scrambled egg dish
and if you missed uncharted
trust me you can watch it on the link
below or on the nat geo app